the donder release saga continues
hours after kanye west's long-awaited
album dropped the rapper took to
instagram claiming that the project was
released without his approval yay wrote
in the post universal put my album out
without my approval and they blocked
jail 2 from being on the album i'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
jail part 2 features de baby and marilyn
manson both of whom currently face
controversy maryland was dropped by his
own record label earlier this year after
a number of women came forward accusing
him of physically mentally and sexually
abusing them claims the shock rocker has
denied
as for de baby his homophobic rant at
the rolling loud festival in miami
earlier this month led him to being
dropped from several other festivals
[Music]
both artists unexpectedly showed up to
kanye's listening party in his hometown
of chicago and confused fans even more
when the baby took over jay-z's verse on
a donda track
but the surprises didn't end there
kanye's ex kim kardashian shocked fans
as she rocked a wedding dress on stage
he's done miracles
it's really lit and fun and crazy yeah
if kanye lighting himself on fire wasn't
enough kim showed up dressed in a
balenciaga wedding gown complete with a
long white veil
of course the reality star filed for
divorce from the rapper after six years
of marriage in february the former
couple share four children north saint
chicago and song we are so blessed to
have the best support system and the
best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through but fans
are now asking the big question did
kimye get back together him and i have
been best friends for a really long time
and just been in each other's lives and
known each other for a long time well a
source recently told et that kim and
kanye are on great terms we have to
thank kim and since they're split she
supported him at his donda listening
events in addition to family outings
with their kids and a recent lunch
together in malibu the source adds quote
kim has had the children lately since
kanye has been working on the album but
co-parenting has been going well for the
couple i've seen him go through a lot
and he's just the most genuine
person and you know he might say things
that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but i
always know his heart and though kanye
claims that donda has been released
without his approval kim was eager to
give the album her stamp of approval by
sharing this on instagram
et has reached out to kanye's camp and
universal music for comment on the
rapper's claims
you